täglich kommen über osteuropa immer mehr
flüchtlinge nach deutschland seit august
sind bereits 5600 migranten aus belarus
über polen eingereist der weißrussische
machthaber lukaschenko versuchte damit
druck auf die eu auszuüben und zwar auf
dem rücken von migranten tja und jetzt
kommen sie als konsequenz hat polens
parlament nun den bau einer grenzmauer
beschlossen müssen wir uns jetzt ein
mauern weil lukas schenk uns erpresst
über trumps mauer zu mexiko da haben wir
uns ja noch aufgeregt über urbans
ungarischen zaun die nase gerümpft und
jetzt plötzlich alles anders ja wir
schauen mal auf die karte wo die mauer
entlang laufen soll und zwar eine mauer
die fünf meter hoch sein soll und sechs
meter breit sie soll tief sie solle
gebaut werden aus stahl und beton
noch sind wir dort wir haben vorhin die
bilder gesehen nur nato und
stacheldrahtzaun aber der soll jetzt
bald ersetzt werden und unser kollege
chefreporter hans jörg vehlewald der ist
für uns in polen in der nähe der grenze
vor ein paar minuten hat er uns sein
aktuelles lagebild geschickt
er hat uns dort geschildert so lange
können wir überbrücken bis die bilder da
sind er hat uns dort geschildert wie
einerseits eben die polnischen
grenzschützer sehr hart vorgehen
andererseits aber viele polen dort
versuchen den flüchtlingen auch sehr
menschlich zu helfen absolut jetzt
sprechen wir mal darüber über die gründe
und die folgen dieser möglichen
grenzmauer will politikchef reporter
peter thiede ist bei uns alexander von
schönburg auch weiter da peter erstmal
zu dir kann polen das einfach so machen
einfach jetzt eine mauer bauen nachdem
wir uns in europa so aufgeregt haben
über genau solche praktiken in anderen
ländern gut also dass wir deutschen der
moralische weltmeister sind ist nicht
ganz neu und wenzel vor unserer haustür
tatsächlich damals um dann zum schwur
kommen dann ist die moral ganz schnell
per du aber die antwort ist natürlich
polen muss das tun polen ist
verpflichtet zum schutz der
aussengrenzen ganz europas verpflichtet
zum schutze seiner außengrenzen
ansonsten hätten wir nämlich keine
schöne reisefreiheit in europa im
berühmten schengen-raum wegfall von
grenzkontrollen in europa hat zur
bedingung dass die außengrenze geschützt
wird mauern sind nun etwas symbolisches
gerade für uns natürlich hier in
deutschland wir sind stolz darauf dass
wir mauern einreißen
müsste man nicht andere methoden finden
einen besseren mehr grenzschützer andere
grenzüberwachung ja gut es ist ein sehr
unübersichtliches gelände über das er da
in polen reden das ist zum beispiel die
als talk das ist ein riesengroßer
naturpark der geht von polen rüber nach
weißrussland erleben wie sind da sind
moore da sind flüsse da kann man nicht
immer grenzschützer durch schicken und
wir lassen sie ihren immer mit mauer
sofort natürlich die berliner mauer
völlig zu recht aber die berliner mauer
war ein weil dort ein land seine leute
eingesperrt da hat sich niemand gegen
außen geschützt man darf sich aber
schützen gegen hybridisierung oder
tatsächliche kriegsführung oder gegen
mafiöse strukturen die vom ausland übel
ein dann eine grenze ausnutzen wollen
das macht polen das muss polen machen
wir haben es bemängelt dass es
griechenland mit seiner seegrenze sehr
sehr lange nicht getan hat und auch mit
seiner landgrenze nicht und das aus der
türkei läuft dann irgendwann wie leute
kamen wir haben uns empört über viktor
orban als er seine hat er seinen zaun
gebaut hat aber das ist die pflicht der
länder an der grenze an den europäischen
außengrenzen
diese auch zu schützen es ist die
pflicht anderer europäischer staaten
diesen staaten dabei zustimmen ganz
spannendes thema wir wollen gleich
weiter trocken ich war allerdings gerade
der beitrag vom kollegen viel wald ist
inzwischen da dem wir uns natürlich
anders
wenn die flüchtlinge werden direkt an
der grenze aufgegriffen und wieder
zurückgeschoben und diejenigen die es
nicht die man nicht ergreifen kann die
landen hier jede nacht auch in dieser
nacht wieder im einzelnen lagern oder in
wäldern oder auf maisfeldern überall
sieht man stellen wo die menschen all
ihr gepäck von sich geworfen haben so
ist der schleuser ihnen befohlen hat sie
gehen dann weitergehen durchflüsse
manche ertrinken so kommt es immer
wieder vor andere werden dass uns
sümpfen gezogen wo sie wirklich von
bauern und nachbarn gerettet werden es
gibt einen unglaublichen gegensatz
zwischen der härte die die polnische
regierung hier zeigen will auch
zugunsten des restes europa und
andererseits der wärme der menschen die
jeden tag dieses leid sehen die
versuchen die menschen zu ihnen zu
helfen ihnen auch etwas zu essen zu zu
stecken dann gibt es noch ärzte und es
gibt anwälte die ebenfalls versuchen in
diese gegend hier zu kommen und sich um
die flüchtlinge zu kümmern was aber
geschehen ist vor zwei monaten ein
ausnahmezustand eine sperrzone circa
fünf kilometer bis nach ein polnisches
gebiet hinein niemand dorf darf dorthin
kein arzt darf sich um flüchtlinge dort
kümmern kein anwalt kann ihnen helfen
asyl zu beantragen
und was immer dort geschieht kann auch
von uns journalisten im moment nicht
genau beobachtet werden denn auch wir
haben keinen zugang zu dieser gegend
dieser sperrzone direkt an der grenze
und der unterschied zwischen dem was die
polnische regierung zeigen will nämlich
härte und der wärme und fürsorge die
hier bei den bewohnern der region zu
spüren ist das ist schon beeindruckend
vor allem ärzte anwälte aber auch
menschenrechtsaktivisten versuchen sie
hier um die belange der flüchtlinge zu
kümmern die sie eben täglich vor augen
haben immer wieder die ihnen immer
wieder begegnen sie versuchen ihnen zu
helfen
aber die sperrzone der ausnahmezustand
hier in der region macht es ihnen
endlich schwer
alexander wenn du diese bilder sieht die
härte einerseits das leid der menschen
andererseits was geht dir durch den kopf
dabei über dieses dilemma indem wir
stecken wie geht durch den kopf dass wir
als medien sehr aufpassen müssen wie wir
das darstellen denn ich glaube das
schlimmste was jetzt geschehen könnte
ist wenn wir es aus sentimentalität
bilder konsumieren und das auf das ist
es leid schauen und über dieses leid
hinweg einfach über die das hinweg
schauen was einfach notwendig ist wie
peter erst gerade gesagt wir müssen nun
mal unsere grenzen schützen denn wenn
unsere grenzen nach außen nicht schützen
dann können bild ist die diese binden
reisefreiheit einfach vergessen und wir
müssen also so schmerzhaft ist wir
müssen unsere grenzen schützen und was
wir dort vor uns haben ist ja nicht nur
flüchtlinge sondern es sind auch einfach
illegale migranten die wissen dass sie
weiß dass sie was illegales machen wir
gehen dorthin mit der absurden
eingeflogen mit der absicht bei uns
eingeschleust zu werden das heißt wir
dürfen uns jetzt auch nicht durch diese
bilder in so einem moralischen zugzwang
bringen lassen aber peter muss es
unbedingt so passieren wer ist jetzt
empfohlen passiert mit dieser härte dir
mit der da vorgegangen also wenn die
berichte stimmen die von verschiedenen
organisationen kommen die aber auch von
den leuten kommen die im grenzgebiet
leben dann verstößt polen dort eindeutig
gegen einige resolutionen und
tatsächlich auch gegen menschen richte
wir hatten neulich mal den fall also der
kollege michael sauerbier aus unserer
brandenburg reaktion der hatte einen
iraker oder einen iraner glaube ich der
ist zwölfmal hin und hergeschoben worden
es wird zwischen beiden ländern da sieht
man aber auch also polen darf nicht
einfach immer wieder zurückgeben aber
man sieht auch da wird wieder krieg
geführt innenminister seehofer sprach
von hybrider kriegsführung und alexander
lukaschenko und unter dem ihr putin
beide setzten genau darauf dass wir
natürlich moralisch da in der absoluten
wiederkommen sie setzen darauf dass es
genau diese elends bilder gibt es ist
ein krieg der bilder es ist ein kalter
krieg der dort geführt wird und eine der
waffen sind die migranten die man dahin
bringt also man spielt mit diesen
menschen deswegen spricht die kanzlerin
auch von staatlich organisierten
menschenhandel und da werden menschen
über die grenze gibt geschoben und uns
um uns auch moralisch zu erpressen und
da bleibe ich mal bei helmut schmidt der
staat darf sich nicht erpressen lassen
aber da müssen wir doch anders
herauskommen aus dieser situation nicht
wir bauern bauen sondern eben auf
politischer ebene mit einem einzigen
land gegangen im einzigen machthaber
anders umgehen ja aber da sind wir beim
grundproblem der deutschen außenpolitik
wir haben unsere staatlichen interessen
unsere interessen im ausland nie klar
definiert das hat historische gründe
gehabt das darf sich aber auch im ändern
und wir müssen wenn wir im ausland tätig
sind wenn wir als gerade als
wirtschaftsnationen aktiv sind und als
politische macht dann müssen wir klar
wissen wir auch was wir in der was wir
in der welt wollen also was sind unsere
interessen und die muss man dann auch
durchsetzen wollen und weil wir sie
vielleicht nicht durchsetzen wollen weil
wir nicht bereit sind tatsächlich auch
auf internationale ebene auch mit harten
bandagen zu spielen definieren wird
diese interessen nicht und wir gehen
dann immer wir sind dann immer im
ausland wie sind für menschenrechte
unterwegs wir sind wir frauen recht
richtungen unterwegs wir scheuen und
manchmal aber auch tatsächlich als
wirtschaftsmacht unterwegs zu sein und
bei gerade bei lukaschenko gerade bei
weißrussland haben wir alle macht der
welt das ist ein wirtschaftszweig der
hat ein bruttoinlandsprodukt so groß wie
köln den können wir schlicht und
ergreifend mit sanktionen in die knie
zwingen er hat zwar noch war dann noch
lange putin hinter sich aber auch den
können wir beeinflussen und tun hätte es
nicht längst weil wir uns da scheuen und
weil wir am ende zum beispiel auch am
gashahn moskaus hängen und weil wir
natürlich dann auch gerade wenn es um
weißrussland geht die mögen ja klein
sein aber die sind eine kartoffel
nationen klingt total banal wir sind
wirklich ein kartoffel an die haben
außer kalisalzen und kartoffeln haben
die nichts was sie ebenfalls was
exportieren können da könnten wir den
hebel ansetzen
wir hätten allerdings alle ein paar
kartoffelchips weniger im regal oder zu
hause weil von daher kommt zum beispiel
der großteil des grundstücks für unsere
kartoffelchips sie kommen aus
weißrussland und dann müssen wir mal
bereits ein ganz kurz uns vielleicht mit
fanny und koma anzulegen
[Musik]